why don't we talk about uh brady's
retirement you know he came out and just
said you know he hasn't said it yet even
his father contacted
david if we can close that door even his
father contacted espn tmz reported
saying look this guy hasn't announced
retirement he contacted the chief saying
listen not the the chiefs but uh
no no the bucks saying oh god look i
haven't made my decision yet where do
you stand do you think he is retired but
he's upset that story leaked yeah well
how could you think he's not retiring at
this point why would that even come into
the atmosphere and people talk about
could you imagine if that's actually not
true and he's like i'm actually coming
back
nonsensical brady is so maniacal that i
think brady
may have had a conversation with a few
people thinking about he's retiring
and that hey here's kind of the
direction i'm going somebody leaked it
brady behind closed doors is so pissed
off that they licked it because he's
always wanted to control the narrative
he wants to come out and say i'm
retiring with a video or a message you
know how he typically does it with a
video that comes out
and uh imagine if he flips and he says
you know what the hell with you guys you
did that i'm gonna go one more year if
there's anybody that can basically flip
it on us it's someone that's basically
saying you think you're going to control
the narrative about me and my life no
i'm coming back we're going to run it
back yeah edelman came out and he said
i'm going to miss you babe or something
like that you know on twitter i said
that edelman oh juliana
but could you imagine
if this is a quote unquote fake news
story james o'keefe type vibe where
you know we can expose the media for
getting it wrong yeah and next thing
you know he's coming back
so ultimately the question is do you
think he is in fact retiring
um uh oh i i have to tell you i think
the conversations took place i think he
is so pissed off right now
i think he's so furious right now that
it leaked to anybody else i don't think
he's the type of guy that would want the
story to leak i think he's lost his mind
with being furious he wanted to do it
his way yeah and it kind of changed it
up but
you know there's some people that are
upset saying listen there's one because
we were at the birthday party it was the
the tico's birthday party when we heard
the announcement okay about uh 10 years
old 10 years old he'll turn 10 tomorrow
and uh people were like no he didn't he
didn't retire yeah he did no he didn't
yes he did tmz saying he didn't so i
don't know do i think he's going to go i
think he can play one more year i think
he can play one more led the league in
yards yeah touchdowns uh but did you see
the completion did you see his last game
when he lost he was not going out
without a fight no no but did you see
it it almost was
you know you you looked at his face at
certain moments it was kind of like do i
like afterwards especially
do i really want to go through this one
more time because think about it if
you're him right now here's what you're
thinking about
who are you going to put around me okay
i need a little bit more help
i got hit a little bit too much okay
maybe antonio brown nonsense yes
receiver went out for the season he had
a couple other injuries like maybe he's
sitting there saying can i do this one
more time what other record is there
left for him to break but you actually a
week ago were saying there's something
about the way he did the press
conference you were actually the one
that was writing on the wall yeah no i
think i think i've never heard him speak
that language you know when somebody
speaks a language like for example
you're sitting with your buddies and
somebody says i'm not gonna lie to you
man you know i'm just sick and tired of
being married this is like freaking very
hard or i'm sick and tired of being
single you're like this guy's never
talked like this before there's
something going on there there's
something going on there okay folks we
got james back here okey for you a nfl
fan tom brady fan do you want to weigh
in on this retirement i used to be a
bills fan when i was a growing up i
loved the bills a lot of elves in that
bill that was eight nine years old and
they lost their fourth straight super
bowl i cried my dad had to say it's just
a game son
in 1994 they lost four scott norwood man
scott norwood
um doug flutie remember doug flutie of
course he was my hero in in high school
i loved boston college came out of cfl
no didn't he start off with the cfo i
went to a giant stadium then giant
stadium in a doug flutie jersey
uh jets fans worst fans
i'm dressed as a bills fan at giant
stadium and they're like throwing fluty
flakes at me and uh but i love doug
flutie he was my my favorite growing up
and i'm sad to see brady retired so i so
when i came to the states 1990 november
28th the football teams you had was
cowboys you had a few different teams i
was a die hard bills fan thurman time
really oh bb bryce pogba wow
there was something unique about this
every i was a bills fan when i came to
the states and i was a lakers fan so for
the first six years i was in bad shape
as a 13 year old kid had therapy
sessions twice a week you know going
through it do you remember the game in
1999 with the the music city miracle
with the titans and the bills yeah but
there was a lot of wars yeah that quite
crushed me yeah right i don't know if
and i think it crashed a lot kevin
yes
that cro they benched doug flutie yeah
and put in rob johnson he lost his shoe
remember that game that was that was my
moment i i never i i used to love that
we've just figured out the spoilers game
do you remember the oilers game
listen my dad was taking me up to san
francisco we're driving up there we're
listening to the radio i'm like i'm
devastated they're down i'm like turn
off the radio i don't want to listen to
it we get to san francisco we get to a
restaurant to eat we look at the screen
it says the greatest comeback of like
your very great [ __ ] bills yeah it
was the comeback nineteen ninety five
something like that maybe this is this
freudian moment you wanna know this this
1999 i remember this game i was obsessed
with the buffalo bills in the 90s
after this game it crushed me
and i know it crushed a lot of people
they benched my hero doug flutie
and they put in rob johnson
anyway so well i think we figured out a
few things here
now the truth has been reviewed we've
been trying to you've elicited the truth
exactly we've been trying to make out
what makes o'keefe that's what pistols
the buffalo bills spelt
do you have a flutie signed jersey or no
i had a fluted jersey yeah i did i used
to wear it to the the jets and the bills
were in the same conference and every
once a year in new jersey meadowlands i
used to go with my dad to see him yeah
awesome well you know the one thing
about sports is it typically takes you
back to a moment with your mom or your
dad or your brother or your sibling yeah
do we want to tell o'keefe the truth
doug flutie come on and we brought doug
if you're watching doug so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you